so
that's a good segue into what do we do
when we have more than one variable the
two models we've considered so far just
perform logistic regression with single
variables but of course if we've got a
collection of variables we want to take
them all into account
and so
in that case we're going to build a
multivariate logistic regression model
so the transformation of the probability
is the same as we had before except now
we've got a general linear model with an
intercept and a coefficient for each of
the variables
and if you invert that transformation
that again gives you a form for the
probability that's guaranteed to be
between 0 and
1. okay well we can fit that using glm
in r just like we did before
and we'll throw in our variable balance
as well
and income and the student variable
and now we get three coefficients three
standard errors
three standard errors
three z statistics and three p values
and the first thing we see here is that
as they were in the single variable case
balance and student are significant
income is not significant
okay so it seems like two of the
variables are important
but here's something rather striking we
notice that the coefficient for student
is negative
while it was positive before
so before when we just measured student
on its own
it had a positive coefficient
but when we fit it in the multivariate
model the coefficient's negative
do you think this is an error rob
i don't think so
so how could that happen
well we remember last time we talked
about in regression models that how
difficult it is to interpret
coefficients in a multiple model b
wealth regression model because the
correlations
between the variables can affect the
science
so there's going to be
we're going to see now the role of
correlations in the variables
so
here's a here's a picture there we see
credit card balance
and
and
and we see the default rate on on
on the vertical axis
and
the brown the students tend to have
let's see so
student status
brown is yes
and blue is no
okay
so students tend to have higher balances
than non-students so the
marginal default rate is higher than for
non-students
okay because we just saw that you know
balance has it plays a role
but what we see in this plot on the left
is that for each level of balance
students default less than non-students
okay
so when you just look at student on its
own
it's confounded with balance
and and and the strong effect of balance
makes it looks like like students are
worse defaulters right
but this plot sort of explains it all
for each level of credit card balance
if we look separately for students and
non-students
students tend to have a lower default
rate
okay
and so
that we can tease out by multiple
logistic regression which takes these
these correlations into account
let's move on to
another example with more variables
we talked about this example in the in
the introduction this is the south
african heart disease data set
remember south africans eat a lot of
meat
rob apparently did i ever tell you the
story about the south africans
more than more than once more than once
i think rob doesn't want to hear the
story again
anyway they do eat a lot of meat so they
did a study in south africa
it was a retrospective study
they went and found 160 cases of white
males who'd had myocardial myocardial
infarction which is a fancy name for a
heart attack
and
amongst
the many people who hadn't had a heart
attack they took a sample of 302
controls right so it's called a case
control sample
and for these people they were all white
males in the age range 15 to 64 and they
were from this western cape region of
south africa
this was done in the early 1980s
so in this region
the overall prevalence was very high for
heart disease 5.1 percent which is very
high risk
so
in this study we have measurements on
seven predictors or also in this case
known as risk factors
and they shown in the scatter plot
matrix which i'll show you right here
so remember the scatter plot matrix is a
very nice way of plotting every variable
against every other variable
and now because it's a classification
problem we can code into the plot the
heart disease status
and so the brown
or red points here are
those cases that had heart disease
and and the the blue points of
the controls
and look at the top plot for example
if you're high in tobacco usage
and your systolic blood pressure is
high you tend to to be a brown point so
those are the people who tend to have
heart attacks
so each of these plot shows a pairwise
plot of two of the risk factors and
codes in the heart disease status you
forgot one risk factor what was that
which is talking with a funny accent
but they've all got that okay
very good rob
i'm doing all the hard work here and
he's just sitting here thinking of jokes
coffee is good too
there's one funny variable here family
history well it's a categorical variable
turns out to be important risk factor
apart from being south african or not
if you have a family history of heart
disease the
the risk is is high
and you can see that it's a zero one
variable in this case and you probably
can see there's more browns in the in
the right hand category than the left
hand category
um
so in this case
we're not really trying to predict the
probability of getting a heart disease
what we're really trying to do is to
understand the role of the risk factors
in
in you know in the in the risk of of
heart disease
and actually this study was it was an
intervention study aimed at educating
the public on healthier diets but that's
that's a whole nother story did it work
um i think it might have worked a little
bit but this is this crowd is really
hard to get them away from their meat
okay
um do you know what they call a barbecue
in south africa no bright lace
okay
every south african loves their
brightness and their bolton
so here's the result of glm
for the heart disease data
and yeah i actually show you some of the
code used to fit it
and we get we'll get into the code
session later but
it's just interesting to see that it's
it's pretty easy to do there's a call to
glm
we
tell it the response is
is chd which is the name of the the
response variable and twiddle means to
be modeled as and dot means all the
other variables in the data frame which
in this case is heart so that's a
data frame that's got all the variables
in in the study
and the response here chd
and we tell it the the family's binomial
which just tells it to fit a logistic
regression model okay
and then we fit that model
save it in in the object called heart
fit
and then we do a summary of hartford
and this is and we get printed out the
summary which is the same summaries that
we've seen before
and so now we get coefficients for each
of the variables
in this column
we get standard errors c values and p
values
and here the story is a little bit mixed
right we're not too interested in the
intercept tobacco usage is significant
low density lipoprotein that's a
cholesterol measure
that's significant
remember there's a good and bad
cholesterol
this is the bad cholesterol
family history
very significant
and age is significant we know the risk
of heart disease goes up with age
now interest in the
obesity
and alcohol usage are not significant
here
which seems a little surprising right
but this is a case again
of having correlated variables if we
look in the previous plot
we'll see you see there's a lot of
correlation between variables
so to back so age and tobacco usage are
correlated
alcohol usage and ldl
are seem to be negatively correlated
ldl is the good
cholesterol so there's lots of
correlations and so those are going to
play a role
and so for example we've got ldl is
significant in the model
and
once ldl is in the model perhaps alcohol
usage is not needed anymore because it's
been taken care of these variables act
as surrogates for each other